[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight and happy Presidents Day
you may have noticed an accelerating
cycle in Washington lately here's what
it looks like
the permanent class hates Donald Trump
they attack him as Ray's best criminal a
foreign spy working to destroy America
Trump because he watches more bad
television than is healthy sees these
attacks and then responds with hostile
tweets attacking his critics his critics
then point out those tweets as evidence
the Trump is every bit as bad as they
said he was and so on well the latest
installment of the saga took place over
the weekend CNN political analyst David
Gergen warned that Trump's criticism of
the media proves he's a would-be
dictator watch discrediting Muller who
started seeing what may come out of
through the Justice Department from
Muller just writing in the press that
we'll be reporting on what Muller does
this is what splits the country apart
and it is the beginnings in many other
countries its beginning it's been the
beginnings of an authoritarian rule and
that's the larger threat hanging over us
now what's kind of hilarious the irony
of course is that David Gergen spent
much of his own career in government not
simply criticizing reporters but
actively lying to them as is the custom
was that the behavior of a despot pretty
funny but pause and consider this
seriously for a MIT authoritarianism
that's what a ruling class says it fears
they tell us that all the time ok let's
say you really were an authoritarian and
you wanted to weaken American democracy
and impose a kind of oligarchy on the
country how would you go about doing
that well you'd probably start by trying
to control what people say and think if
citizens dissented from the mandated
orthodoxy or dared to consider
unauthorized ideas you'd target them you
shame them on social media you'd shout
them down in public you'd get them fired
from their jobs you'd make sure
everybody was afraid to disagree with
you after that you would work to disarm
the population you take their guns away
that way they'd be entirely dependent on
you for their safety not to mention
unable to resist your plans for them
then just to make sure you'd quelled all
opposition you'd systematically target
any and
tution that might oppose or put brakes
on your power you'd be especially
concerned about churches the family and
independent businesses you'd be certain
to undermine and crush those using laws
and relentless propaganda if despite all
of that election results still didn't go
your way you'd use an entrenched
unelected bureaucracy to neuter any
leader you hadn't hand-picked yourself
well you'd be shaken by an election like
that you'd resolve never to allow one
again and to make sure of that
you'd work tirelessly to replace the old
and ungrateful population with a new and
more obedient one that's what you do
sound familiar we're not talking about
Donald Trump for all of his faults Trump
isn't doing any of that a ruling class
is and that's what all these issues are
really about the speech codes the calls
for gun control the relentless attacks
on the nuclear family the demands for
unlimited mass immigration none of that
is designed to help you none of it will
make you happier or more prosperous
that's not the point
the point is to make you more dependent
on the very people who are yelling at
you right now on cable television
they're the authoritarians